let's go to our next caller why don't we
go to the 8th 1/8 area code caller from
8 1 8 tell us who you are and what's on
your mind today
hey David this is a Chris from Los
Angeles hmm and I had a quick question
do you think we're headed for a
recession and the reason why I ask this
is there's a couple factors that I'm
thinking about the rising interest rates
by the Fed we just came out today that
the home sales declined 12 percent over
last year auto loan defaults are up and
there's also an inverted yield curve yep
which predicts a recession so what are
your thoughts about the upcoming you
know year and is the economy gonna get
better with the Peris there's a lot of
factors going into there okay so I'll
answer the last part first the economy
is not going to get better because of
the tariffs number one but here's the
thing yes there is another recession
coming now why do I say that I say that
because in history there has always been
another recession coming I don't pretend
to know when it is I don't pretend to
know when it's going to be here I think
that we are really really bad at
predicting these things when President
Obama was running for his second term
and Mitt Romney was making all sorts of
promises about the economy and President
Obama was making all sorts of promises
it was pretty clear that not necessarily
the next four years but like the next
three to 5 3 to 6 years were probably
going to be pretty good economically
barring some kind of acute catastrophe
and they were and I think in the economy
would have also been pretty good if Mitt
Romney had become President of the
United States although there might have
been somewhat of a delta right it might
have been slightly better slightly worse
me the trajectory would have been
similar likewise so far in the trump
presidency it's not shocking that we've
had the stock market run up that we've
had however correctly eventually we are
going to have a recession which
indicators do I look at I don't look at
any particular indicator I think that
there's there's no real way to know
exactly when it's coming I do think that
the fact that wages and purchasing power
have been stagnant in the United States
even though cost of living has been
going up and
at some point that is going to become a
problem I look at like macro indicators
like massive inequality when we continue
to see more and more departure from the
very rich and the very poor at some
point that's going to implode when it's
going to happen I don't know he great
thanks for your insight and I appreciate
your show I'm a member
thank you signed up I got the half the
50% off now so I signed up right away
and I'm glad to know you and thank you
for having me on all right Chris
appreciate it and that was not a staged
call by the way because he's a member or
anything like that he it was that's a
totally real phone call and and why
would I even mention that it wouldn't be
real anyways that me me being paranoid I
don't know